-Kenan, I wanted
to ask you about this.
This is very, very cool.
Demi, I don't know
if you saw this.
-I did see that.
-Kenan got a star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. That was awesome.
-I couldn't be happier
for you, bud.
What was --
-Peep the bowtie.
-Yeah, looking --
You're looking sharp.
But, I mean, that's
an amazing accomplishment.
-It looks like I left there
and started selling bean pies.
-Yeah, no, no.
Did -- Did you --
What was it like?
What's the vibe there, though?
-You know, it was --
it was amazing.
It was very surreal.
My whole family was there.
You know, generations of family
and stuff like that.
So it was just very touching.
It was hot.
-Yeah.
-You could -- You could see it
on my little one's face.
Like, she was not having it.
-She was like,
"This is just too hot.
Hurry -- Hurry this up."
-She was over it.
Yeah, she wanted
chicken fingers.
So...
-Yeah, yeah. She did.
You sent me a picture,
which I am glad.
Because you're on
the carpet here.
Look. Isn't this nice?
You're wearing the bowtie.
You got the thing and the star
and the red carpet.
-The red carpet out there.
That's nice.
-Yeah, and then, under the red
carpet, you see this poking out.
-Yeah, on the side.
-That's Lorne Michaels.
-Yes.
-How disrespectful.
How disrespectful...
-Yeah, it seemed real dis--
Just half-covered.
-...to the great Lorne Michaels.
-Yeah, that's just --
That's cold, Lorne Michaels.
-He got Phantom of the Opera'd.
-Yeah.
-He got Phantom'd.
-Cover the whole thing up.
You know?
-Yeah, don't even let you know
that you're over Lorne's star.
-Peeking at me. It's weird.
He's always watching.
-But you're next to --
You're next to Lorne's star.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-That's kind of cool.
-It's unbelievable, man.
Like, I mean,
when are you getting yours?
You're getting yours...?
[ Audience oohs ]
...soon?
I'm genuinely --
I'm genuinely asking.
-Yeah, they told me
that they were full.
-They're full up?
-They told me that
the sidewalk was full.
-I saw a couple of spaces.
-They said,
"We have enough stars, yeah."
-I'm gonna go ahead and advocate
for Jimmy to get his star ASAP.
Am I right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, yeah.
-You've put in more work
than I have.
-I put some work in, right?
-I'm here for it.
-But I didn't --
I'll tell you what I didn't do.
-What?
-"Good Burger."
-Oh, look at the "Good Burger"
little kiddy faces.
Look at those little babies.
-I have to say, I had this
on an orange VHS tape.
-You had the orange tape?
-Yes, I had the orange tape.
-Oh, amazing.
-That's legit. That's real.
-Yes. Yes.
-Nickelodeon.
-VHS tapes were a way for...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. They understand.
-...people to watch movies
in the '90s, yeah.
-And this is 25 years ago.
-Yeah, that's crazy.
Anybody feeling old yet?
-No.
-When you first met
Kel Mitchell,
when you got together,
did you go,
"Oh, we got a little chemistry"?
Did you feel like, "Oh,
we're gonna be funny together"?
-When we started
working together, because, like,
we were kids, so we had school
at first, and I was a nerd.
So, like, all the other kids
had met each other.
They had, like, a pizza party,
and I was hired kind of last,
so I missed all the, like,
introduction night or whatever.
-Oh, no!
-So, my first --
my first day was that morning.
And, you know, everybody was
just doing their school work,
and I was super quiet, so
everybody was looking at me
like I was standoffish
or -- or whatever.
And then we started rehearsing.
And we did these characters
called Mavis and Clavis,
which were these two
kind of, like,
old Black guys in a balcony,
like, heckling people
or whatever.
-Mavis and Clavis.
And, yeah, we've been --
-Two friends.
Their names happen
to rhyme with each other.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Never met each other.
They just came together. 'Cause
it's -- it's sketch comedy.
-"Yeah, that's interesting.
Your name rhymes with mine."
-Yeah, and I just
immediately recognized
that he was brilliant, you know?
And we were very similar,
so then we just hit it off
from that point.
So it was very much
a day-one kind of thing.
-Yeah. I know this is
a little cryptic here, but...
At the bottom, it says,
"What's up with that part two?"
-Yeah, what's up
with that part two?
You know what I'm saying? What's
up with that sequel there?
You know what I mean?
-Wait. So what are you saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drum roll ]
-Yes!
-Are you saying --
Are you saying that
"Good Burger 2" is happening?
-I would like it to.
-Okay.
[ Drum roll stops abruptly ]
[ Laughter ]
That's very anticlimactic.
-Very anti--
"I would love to annou--"
No, we are, you know, working
harder on it than -- than ever.
So it's about, you know,
meeting the numbers,
letting the numbers match up,
'cause I need them numbers.
You know what I'm talking about.
-Oh, stop it. You're not
even looking at anyone.
You weren't even looking at --
-You guys --
You guys feel me, right?
-There's no one there.
Do you have an idea for it?
-You know the numbers
I need, man.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have any idea
of what it would be about?
-Uh --
-No.
-I feel like Kel should have,
like, a million kids.
Like, Ed's character should
have, like, a million kids.
And then, like, I'm coming out
of jail for something
that he put me in jail for.
[ Laughter ]
-That he did and you -- yeah.
And he had a great life.
You went to prison. Yeah, yeah.
Can you believe that you're
going into the 20th season
of "Saturday Night Live"?
Two-zero.
-Yeah. Two-zero. It's crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
20 years.
-This is legendary status.
Legendary status.
-I mean, I agree with you, sir.
It is legendary status.
I don't know how to, like,
process that, man.
You know what I'm saying?
It's still all about, like --
-I mean, we were there --
How do you --
Do you remember the years
we were together?
-It was only one year.
Like, I remember you being
the biggest damn near rock star
on the show.
You know what I'm saying? Like,
you didn't really do much work.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I want my star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Only because
you were so seasoned at --
You could just come, float in,
do whatever you wanted,
and, like, that was cool.
Like, you didn't even feel
the pressures of anything.
Like, you did --
We did a "Grease" sketch
where you had to sing, like,
that super high-pitched
John Travolta.
And you -- you crushed that.
Like, not a lot of people
can squeak up that "high."
♪ High ♪
You know what I'm talking about?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And it was you and Tina.
And y'all just seemed like y'all
were married, and that was cool
and just, like, best friends.
-Yeah.
-And it was --
it was an interesting,
like, brotherhood to join.
Brotherhood/sisterhood.
-Yeah.
-And I was so happy
that y'all were like
my -- my older siblings.
You know, I have such --
-And then I left you
in the dust.
-In the dust. Completely.
And went to do, like,
mad movies.
-Yeah, I said,
"Son, take care of this place."
-Yeah, and then you came --
you came back home.
-I came back home.
-Right to the sixth floor.
-I did.
-We're -- We're right upstairs.
-I see you all the time. I'm
always rooting for you, buddy.
-Nice having you back home, Dad.
Thanks.
It's good. Good times.
-I promised I wouldn't cry.
-Yeah.
-I promised everyone
I wouldn't cry.
Can we talk about the Emmys?
-Let's talk about the Emmys.
I'm hosting it.
-You're hosting the Emmys.
-Bing, bong, bang! Yeah.
-You've won on Emmy.
You've been nominated for Emmys.
Do you remember
first going to the Emmys?
-Yeah, my first time
actually going, I had to open
the show with Kate doing
this, like, song and dance.
And we --
-Oh, yeah. I remember that.
-Yeah, with, like,
all the other, like, I think --
I want to say
NBC kind of talent.
And it was, like,
a full-on week of rehearsal.
And we had just won
the previous week.
-That's your first time
at the Emmys.
-My first time.
-You opened it.
-So it was like
a two-week experience.
We won at the Creative Emmys
the week before
for "Come Back, Barack."
And then, yeah, we --
My first time going,
I had to open the show.
Big, big-ass stage. Crazy.
-What do you think
are the ingredients
for a good awards show?
-Not to bore everybody like
I hope I'm not doing right now.
-No.
-Yeah, 'cause it gets
kind of redundant, I guess.
You know there's gonna be, like,
20, 30 awards or something.
So you don't want people to,
like, you know, get up there
like the NBA draft
and they're like,
"I want to thank God,
my family, and, you know.
I want to try hard."
You know,
like that Bill Burr joke.
But it's my job to, like,
keep everything fresh and hype
and, you know, celebrating,
you know, artistic creativity.
-I don't think they could have
picked a better human
to host this.
-Oh, man. Thank you, man.
-Kenan Thompson.
Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
-Kenan Thompson, everybody.
Hosting the Emmys, live,
September 12th on NBC.
They're also streaming
on Peacock.
-Right.
-Jeremy Allen White
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.